>>Peter: One of our goals
here at School Twenty-One is
to create interesting people, who have
passions, who care about the world
around them, who want to
change things, who are curious.
We need to make school once
more a place of joy and wonder,
where you're being stretched and
challenged and motivated every day.
>>Student: Who here have dreams
and goals they want to
achieve in their life?
>>Peter: So at School
Twenty-One, everything's a jigsaw.
By seeing it in action, you see how the
different strands feed of each other.
Wellbeing is a way of wrestling
with issues about themselves
and about others that go quite deep.
>>Student: Boys can wear pink
and boys can play with dollies.
It's their choice and--
>>Peter: And through drama
techniques, through literature,
through conversations with
each other and with teachers,
students are exploring in a really
sophisticated way their emotions,
their qualities, what's getting in the
way of their learning and getting on.
>>Anna: Does skin color tell you
much about a person on the inside?
>>Students: No.
>>Peter: So what we're developing, and
why wellbeing links so well to oracy is
that if you're well inside yourself,
if you've got confidence,
then you will speak.
>>Student: Isn't this
country a democracy?
>>Peter: Oral communication is up there
as one of the most important skills
and we wanted students to find their
voice, metaphorically and literally.
>>Student: Everybody's people.
>>Peter: Oracy and wellbeing
link to project based learning,
because if they're producing
work of a really high standard,
that makes them feel
better about themselves
and really proud of what they've done.
It's a very clever way of combining
knowledge, skills and attributes.
So you're applying in depth
knowledge to real situations,
and I think it's very
stimulating for the students.
We genuinely believe here in educating
the whole child, and developing them
in all their characteristics so that
they can make a difference to the world
when they go out of school.